I would like to begin with an acknowledgement
that we live in a golden age of the web platform.
Every now and then, there's an article which
comes and does the rounds which states that
the web is dying, or already dead, and I really
disagree with this.
CSS Grid, Flexbox, variable fonts, service
workers, the tools we need to build progressive
web applications - we have very powerful building
blocks at our disposal.
This is not the sign of a web dying, this
is the sign of a web which is very much alive
and thriving.
We have these web standards coming in browsers
at a faster rate than ever before.
The process is more transparent than ever
before.
The gaps are narrowing.
We also have access to a litany of frameworks
and libraries, and, while there is cause to
feel overwhelmed - I know - I need to acknowledge
that we have a tremendous amount of choice
out there with which to build our tools.
And, to get us through that, we have at our
disposal a lot of developer tools from build
tool chains all the way through to DevTools
and browsers, and, acknowledging the differences,
I could still say that DevTools in all browsers
today provide a robust tool kit that empower
web developers to create for the web platform.
Web developers.
What about web designers?
My name is Razvan, and, today, I want to talk
about DevTools for web designers.
I'm a software engineer at Mozilla, I work
on Firefox DevTools, and, previously to this,
I worked on a bunch of things at Adobe like
CSS Shapes, regions, masking, blend modes,
and many other things that never actually
made it.
Throughout my career, I always have been interested
in the sort of tools we can provide for these
powerful new features.
Now, it's good to begin with a bit of back
story of how we got to this point.
Firebug was a very, very popular Firefox extension
which revolutionised the way we develop.
Itself was inspired, and it competed with,
the sort of tools like DOM inspector.
What set apart Firebug was a community of
enthusiast developer from different companies,
ecosystem of extensions, and people who wanted
to build better tools right into the context
of the browser so we could get inspection,
we dug debugging, and many other things.
Firebug was a pioneer in developer tools,
and it is the pioneer of and which many DevTools
are based today.
When it comes to web design features, the
pioneer I would like to point out is Dabblet,
CSS playground built by Lea Verou, which is
an interesting way of showing property previews
on CSS.
She collected some of the examples at the
time and collected them into Dabblet for us
to use.
It serves as an inspiration for DevTools,
and sometimes, it makes me sad would be today,
we have DevTools which do not yet match Dabblet
in expressiveness.
What do web designers actually need in order
to design in the browser?
I think it is good to make the distinction
by what I mean by web designers, and that
is people who predominantly use CSS and HTML
in their work.
Not to say they don't use JavaScript, but
their work is primarily in CSS and HTML.
I think there are a few key principles that
DevTools would need to solve in order for
people to truly design in the browser.
These are things like the free form canvas
where you can explore ideas in an unhindered
manner with less structure to worry about.
The confidence that your changes will not
be lost and you can undo them.
Web designers also need specialised tools
for the sort of problems they solve.
A simple form with input fields is not enough,
and they also want their tools to be flexible
and customisable to fit the way they work.
So let's get into it.
Freedom.
By freedom here, I mean bringing in some of
the creative freedom that people have in tools
like Photoshop or Sketch, where it is easy
to start designing something and let your
creativity flow and allow for the serendipitous
moments when you stumble upon a design that
you like.
That's not to say we do it in tools or in
the browser today, but that it is less expressive
and conducive to experimentation to write
code when you want the solution as opposed
to free-form editing.
No DevTools actually solves this today because
this is a very complex problem to solve.
The web is built over very many years, and
it has to be backwards compatible, and it
has to lend itself to progressive enhancement.
With one tool which comes close to this is
web flow.
Web flow is a tool, an online he had for for
creating websites in a completely manual way,
just dragging things around, and using specialised
editors.
This is a video I pulled from their website
which highlights some of the functionality
you have there.
It is a lot more expressive, and it is a lot
more fast to get to results with web flow.
Even it, which exports good-quality code,
from the editor, it needs to fit into their
CMS ecosystem, and it needs some form of structure
in order to build these things, so you don't
have true free capabilities to put things
wherever you want, you still have some form
of limitations in structure, but it's getting
very close.
While the freedom aspect of DevTools is not
solved in a general sense, I do believe per
component, key can still have tools which
give you free-form editing capabilities.
Next up is confidence.
Picture this: you're doing a design in Photoshop,
you make some changes, you made a mistake.
There is no way to go back.
Or you accidentally refresh the tool, and
all of your changes have gone.
Well, sadly, that is the situation in many
of the DevTools today.
The changes are very ephemeral.
You come in, make tweaks, refresh the page,
and they're gone.
That's not something you can use as a professional
tool if you don't have control over these
tweaks.
Changes are happening, though.
There is a new feature launched recently in
Chrome called Local Overrides.
What that does is it tracks changes happening
in DevTools, writes them to a file, and then
reapplies them every time you refresh the
browser, so you don't lose changes any more.
Here's a video of it in action in Chrome.
You find it under the sources panel.
There's the overrides sub panel there.
You first need to select the folder where
you would save the changes, the whole file
changes.
Once you allow this, you can return to your
normal work flow in DevTools.
So you can start making changes to properties
and the browser will start monitoring those
changes, and it essentially saves an entire
copy of the file to disk, so, then, when you
refresh, even hard refresh, like clearing
the cache, you always get your changes back
from that file on disk.
There is an indicator in the network panel
saying, "By the way we may be overwriting
properties."
As soon as you disable DevTools, you're back
to the normal website.
When you re-enable DevTools, local changes
are always reapplied.
Essentially, it's taking the local file and
using it instead of what is coming from the
server, which is great, but there's a caveat:
if you forget this thing open, you may not
know why your dev changes are not applying
on your machines.
There's a caveat there on which you need to
be mindful.
The indicator next to the network panel is
a hint there.
An alternative to local overrides is a Chrome
developer tools citizens called Finch Developer
Tools.
It does pretty much the same thing.
You have to explicitly enable it.
There is no folder to save.
Once you enable Finch, you can start making
changes to your style and DevTools as usual.
It monitors the changes and saves them into
memory.
Every time you refresh the page, it goes to
memory and brings the changes back.
You have the panel called DevTools which shows
you a diff of everything you've done which
you can toggle on and off, and you can export
these changes.
And the difference with Finch is that you
can export just the subset of changes you
made immediately of having a future file saved
locally to disk.
Next up, it is specialised tool, and there's
lots to talk in specialised tools.
By this, I mean editors focused on doing one
thing and doing it very, very well.
Probably, the classic example in specialised
tools, is the colour-picker.
The colour-picker in Chrome, I'm convinced
everyone has used it before, you start inspecting
an element, you find a colour value, and you
trigger the colour-picker over there, and
you make changes to the hue and see your changes
live on the page.
This is powerful because we want contextual
changes.
I don't know if you've noticed recently, there's
a recent addition of contrast ratio which
tells you if the colours you're picking are
compliant with accessibility guidelines which
make text easier to read for people who have
difficulty reading text of different colours.
Once you change colours, you actually get
a line over there, and it shows you the threshold
above which colours are not considered compliant
with the standards, double A or AAA.
I particularly like this integration of accessibility
right into the tool when you're developing
as opposed to having an accessibility step
later down the road.
It brings the importance of the field up close
and personal.
I like this.
Next up, the text shadow editor, also in Chrome
DevTools.
I don't know if you've noticed this because
it is very subtle, but in the styles panel
of Chrome DevTools, there's a hamburger, or
meat ball menu, giving you more options to
add properties.
One of these is properties is adding the shadow.
This gives you a specialised editor which
gives you a lot more flexibility in playing
around with the shadow, changing the direction
of it, or the spread, or the blur, which,
again, lends itself to creativity, to exploration,
to figuring out what works and what doesn't.
Next up, the CSS Grid inspector.
People love CSS grids because they're an amazing
new layout tool and they need help designing
with Grid.
CSS Grid is actually being used on the website
conference right now.
The Grid inspector gives you a preview of
the grid so you can inspect where the elements
are actually positioned on that grid.
Here's a more complex example built by my
colleagues, Jen Simmons, where the need for
the Grid inspector comes in handy because
you want to know where the positions are on
the grid.
You can toggle the display line numbers, and
you can extend the lines infinitely if that
helps you or not.
A cool thing is you can change the colour
of the grid, so you maybe have more contrast
if it doesn't work well with your design,
and the setting is maintained after you refresh
the page.
So I know for a fact that this demo is also
responsive, and, when you make changes, this
is where the inspector comes in very hand
which, because some elements may have repositioned,
and then you can see them on the grid inspector,
and you can understand what changed in your
layout.
This is an invaluable tool if you're learning
Grid, or if you're playing with Grid, because
it can get very complex, and having a specialised
preview in the grid inspector is really useful
for people.
CSS filters in Firefox: they have an editor
in Firefox DevTools.
There are really cool ways of changing the
graphic of something, the styling.
So, over here, we're using the filter editor
to add a hue rotate and dragging against that
label over there to pick up colours for a
hue rotate, and we can also add, for example,
brightness, so we can change and stack multiple
filters together, and, what makes this very
powerful is that, instead of writing the values
manually, you can play around with them, and
you don't need to know their limits, their
constraints.
You can also saturation to see what desaturation
does, and an important thing about filters
is that their order is important, so you can
change the order in the editor, and you can
live-preview that on the page to understand
the subtle differences that are actually happening
when you're doing that.
One thing which is not shown in the video
is that you can also save these filters presets,
so you can reapply them next time you want
to edit.
Next up, the CSS gradient editor.
We have a gradient editor integrated into
the Safari DevTools, wherever you see a linear
repeat ing gradient, you get a contextual
editor to do this, and this is on grabient.com
which is a playground for choosing gradients
or creating them online and getting them.
There are a lot of great editors out there.
People are trying to solve this problem in
many different ways, and it's really good
to have a lot of different opinions.
One very cool gradient editor that I found
recently is one for easing gradients.
So, Andreas Larsen suggested introducing the
concept of easing to your gradients like we
have in animations, so you don't have a straight
gradient, you can have a curve.
He built this specialised editor to represent
what this a would mean.
This is a CSS working group proposal now.
You can use the editor to understand the intent.
You can change the angle of the grade went,
change colours, one cool feature which I love
a lot is using steps to have a stepped linear
gradient over there, and I love this tool
so much because it's so focused on letting
you explore different things.
I have literally spent hours playing with
this tool.
And, yes, it doesn't solve all problems for
Grid but this is a prime example of a tool
doing one thing and doing it very well while
encouraging creative exploration.
I really, really like this.
Enough of video demos, let's switch to some
code.
This is something being developed now in Firefox
Nightly, and called the font editor.
For this, I'm going to switch over and over
and open up the Firefox DevTools.
I'm showing this in Firefox nightly.
We built this thing called the font editor
which is an extra panel over here in the side
bar that allows you to edit things for fonts,
like you can change the size, - sorry, we
need to inspect the element, and then we need
to not have our demo crash on stage.
Sorry.
That's why it's behind the flag right now.
Finally to the it working.
This is behind the flag ... [Applause].
This is behind the flag in Firefox Nightly
because it has bugs.
It won't have bugs soon enough.
What we can do with the font editor, check
the element and then the size of it.
We're used to this and make it Italic or not.
The font editor is built for helping you use
variable fonts, and variable fonts are very,
very cool because they change the way we use
fonts in our website, instead of downloading
multiple font files, variable fonts include
information in the font file that allows the
browser to generate bold, italic, or many
different things with axis.
It goes and reads the font file and give you
access to those axis.
We're changing the weight of our font here.
You can probably see that the font weight
doesn't go up in increments of 100, you can
have fined-grained control depending on the
font author.
We can change the width of
the font.
These are called registered axis which means
they're expected to be there for the most
variable fonts.
They're not expected but - the very, very
cool thing about variable fonts is that you
can build custom axes into the font file as
an author, and we can expose those in the
font editor.
Here, we can change the ascender height, so
the ascender is making our case, our Bs, our
Ks, a lot small, or change the serif height
is more subtle to see on stage, but it definitely
works in tweaking the font to your desired
behaviour.
What makes this very powerful is that, in
order to do these things are variable fonts,
you have to read the font file, read the documentation,
and know that piece custom axes exist.
I'm going to turn on a mode called Free Paint
Mode in Firefox so you can see what is happening.
The actual notation you need to write by hand
is in font variation he gets settings.
It is a bit cryptic if you want to write this.
The font editor comes in handy when you want
to do these things and explore, and drive-by
exploration of variable fonts on the web.
We're working on this in Firefox Nightly.
Thankfully, it's behind the flag.
This and variable fonts are coming very, very
soon.
If you're interested in variable fonts, this
is a website I recommend you check out.
Axispraxis is a playground for variable fonts
which does pretty the same as our font editor.
It gives you the axis so you can play with
them.
The font editor, you can go on any website
and have them work for you.
Next, the shape path editor.
This is an editor for helping you use CSS
shapes and clip path notation in a very visual
way.
So, over here, I'm going to turn on this demo
again, and, what is probably very visible
is that I have my text wrapping around the
tree over there.
The way it's doing that is using a CSS property
called shapeoutside which changes the float
rectangle.
That's a Polygon representation over there
which I doubt anyone would write by hand.
For this, we have the CSS shaped path editor.
We can enable it by clicking here.
We get an overlay of an editor, so we can
drag these points around.
[Applause].
Thank you.
So we can drag these points around, double-click
to remove them, and we can see our changes
happening contextually on the page.
This is important because it interacts.
You need to do this on the page so you can
understand what is going on.
Here's a trick.
We can hold down the control key on windows
or the command key, and press this thing.
Now we get a transforms editor which allows
us to change the entire shape up and down.
We can also rotate the shape.
We can scale it, many crazy different things.
This is working for shape-outside properties
right now, but it also works for clip paths
because they use the same value notation.
What is an Alice in Wonderland demo without
the Cheshire Cat?
It has been watching us from up here.
I can review.
By watching this element which has a clip
path circle very small.
As I drag this handle here, I can reveal ... [Applause].
[Laughter].
We were clipping an element.
Thank you.
We were actually clipping this element with
the clip path.
Again, the notation for circle is relatively
easy, but you can imagine this being handy
for polygons which it also works for.
An extra thing you see there is the rectangle
informing you of the extent of the element
which would be clipped, so you understand
if say, for example, you don't see why clipping
doesn't happen outside of it, that is your
representation.
So these are tools that we are building to
empower you to play with features right into
the browser.
Specialised tools.
Now, CSS shapes is I think done in Firefox,
and it's imminent, like the release is imminent.
Next couple of weeks, I believe.
So, Shapes are coming in Firefox and the Shape
Editor launching at the same time.
Alleys switch over to the last part which
is ergonomics.
This means that people really love tools when
they can customise them to suit the way they
work.
People work in many different ways throughout
our industry.
And that's probably not news to you.
But what maybe is news is that the developer
tools team in any browser you know has very
few people working on it, and there is generally
very few people maintaining codebase for a
large, large audience.
Some of us are thankful to have contributors
like volunteers we have at Mozilla who fix
bugs, and who even implement features altogether,
and we are really thankful foyer their effort
but the reality is we need to work against
some priorities, and sometimes, those priorities
may not be the same thing you care about.
And, when people want something built, they
just go ahead and do it.
So, I was really happy to learn earlier this
month that a Chrome DevTools extension now
has over one million users.
As much as we love React in DevTools, I think
it is hard to imagine that anyone would prioritise
building DevTools for React into DevTools
knowing how transient and ever-changing frameworks
are.
That didn't stop people who were motivated
and skilled enough to build these tools and
share them with others.
They recognise the need, build the tool for
it, and this is popular.
This is the power of billing extensions.
So, at this point, I should just encourage
you all to build DevTools extensions for web
designers.
Well, I could do that.
Well, you can get a panel added to your DevTools
- like my extension over there - or you can
get a sidebar panel placed next to the rules
over there.
If you're using free-paint mode in Firefox,
you have the rules panels separate and you
have a design surface next to it, and you
can see those changes happening in the rule
view.
But if that panel looks very lonely and empty,
it is because it is.
In reality, DevTools extensions are very,
very isolated.
They know almost nothing about the DevTools
environment, and they have a very loose connection
with the inspected page through rudimentary
text-based protocol.
So, if you want to build DevTools, for designers,
you don't actually have access to the rule
view.
You don't know which rules have applied to
that element.
You don't know if the node is changing.
You don't knee if the DevTools has closed
underneath your feet.
That's kind of weird.
So, if you want to build DevTools extensions
right now, you have to do a lot of work just
to get to the point where you can start building
your specialised editor.
Now, that's not a good way of working.
So, here comes a proposal: what if we could
change that?
What if we can write extension APIs that allow
you to plug into the rule view and subscribe
with the specialised editor for a property?
Say, you want to write an editor for font
weight which has a slider with notches over
there, and maybe a dropdown to pick one of
the instances.
The browser should do the leg work of closing
your editor and events in the change, and
then sending events by something else.
But there's no real reason why we expose this
one editor at
a time.
.... So we can
have
a font size editor which allows you to see
what you're picking is not legible or not,
or margin that does shorthand ex-pangs over
there.
These would be inline editors, and I give
you the freedom to really focus on something
you want to implement, a specialised editor.
We can also open up the previews, so we can
have previews of angles.
This is a demo built by one of my colleagues.
We can get closer to the vision Leah had and
ex pose the tool tip to preview one at a time.
If we have an extension ecosystem and the
browser knows these extensions exist in the
store, then it could get to a point where
we could smartly look at something, see a
property that there's an editor for, and we
can recommend this to you in context, so you
can install an extension for DevTools right
in context, and solve the problem as you are
there.
Now, if these things sound interesting to
you, and if you want to build extensions like
these, if you're a web designer that wants
extensions built for them like this, we're
very, very interested in hearing from you.
Please reach out to me or my colleagues in
Firefox DevTools.
We want to understand what classes of problems
you're trying to solve, so as to build an
API which really serves your needs well, because
we're really interested in building tools
that work well for you.
Because, until we do that, we are always going
to do some form of limitation in the creative
expression you get into DevTools, and we cannot
design in the browser unless we make DevTools
for designers actually good.
Thank you very much.
[Applause]